I know okay
can we play this this is the same body
worn camera video just in slow motion
slow motion stop right there
so at this point this is where he
reached out and pulled the blue steel
semi-automatic pistol out of his pocket
okay continue
he raised his left hand stop one shot
you can see the smoke coming from the
muzzle continued second shot the officer
as he runs away he's trying to gain
control two shots are fired at some
point biock still in a semi not upright
and that's where we found it two
additional casings really to see that
video one more time would it be helpful
and just run through it okay okay let's
just go through
so at this point as he's going down he
is still actively firing his weapon and
this is when the additional officers
engaged him but I just want to make note
as you can see in the video that the
officer who was initially fired upon
showed tremendous courage and pursuing
an armed suspect who clearly fired two
shots in his direction and it's a simply
a miracle that he wasn't struck in the
head we don't know how close because he
was aiming the pistol as you can see
when once he raised down we could just
stop right there and you can see the
officer two to three feet away aimed
directly at his head but a miracle he
wasn't struck by gunfire
he had been hit at this time again
attended four shots were fired by
officers total four shots fired by the
suspect
breakdown yes so four shots were fired
by three officers went officer fired one
shot another officer fired one shot and
then the third officer fired two shots
I'm not certain unless we know it was
truck four times again his job said his
shots did not take effect can we turn
the lights back on please
I think you may have sustained at least
one headshot suspect yeah 25 auto
semi-automatic beretta when I report out
early I said a 22 I believe based on
information that it was a 22 well it was
it was clear during the early phases of
this investigation once protesters got
on scene there was significant agitation
then suddenly there were other
individuals that were converging on a
location who were equally angry and one
of the things that they kept repeating
was what they got off of social media
platform and what they were hearing in
fact some of it ranges from he was
unarmed there was a report that he was
unarmed seated on the porch and
basically in my war is not necessarily
theirs he was executed clearly when you
look at the video and what we know in
the investigation that was not true and
so it was so important for us to get
this information out as soon as we can
this is unprecedented for the
investigators to get it done and again
an investigation is still going but to
be able to get the body worn in car -
within hours of this investigation we
talked about the miracle relative to
this officer and I had a chance to talk
to him later and he's clearly as you
would imagine shaken up but it's a
miracle we were able to get this
together so quickly no it was not this
was as I reported earlier there was a
mass shooting if you will on July 5th
morning at a big block party where eight
people were shot three
I officers from the 12th precinct and
the gang Intelligence Unit were there
engaging in surveillance they knew about
this target that they went to arrest
they saw him as depicted in the video he
offered no resistance in fact he's taken
into custody without incident well it
does it doesn't cite violence and I was
deeply concerned over the enrolling this
information I know we're in a very
difficult time not just here but across
this country and I've asked repeatedly
that you know give us a chance I know
that the officer-involved shooting
incidents that we've been involved here
the the city has treated me in the
department well they trust this
department we give information as
quickly as we can in fact this
investigation was probably not even an
hour old when I arrived at scene was
briefed on what took place and I wanted
to get the information out as quickly as
I could I do I run a risk absolutely
because I know as investigation has
progressed back some time change and I
was concerned about that and so that's
why I saw was so important to get the
facts right the first time and I have to
make adjustments then I'll do that but I
think that has gone a long way and
building trust in this community and so
when we say it happened a certain way
most people tend to believe that
certainly there was an individual
leading the protests who had another
agenda it was someone who's putting out
false information and it did have an
impact on inciting what mostly has been
peaceful protesters I'm glad you brought
that up
that was another erroneous report that
was put out
that didn't happen as you saw in the
video again eight shots in five seconds
eight shots in five seconds four by
three police officers and four by the
suspect mr. Littleton well it's clear
that without facts you make a statement
that gets people upset they're angry and
that's why it's so important as law
enforcement that we set the record
straight as soon as we possibly can but
we need to do a proper and thorough
investigation and it's not always as
simple thank God for body-worn cameras
and cams because then it's me telling
the story based on the investigation and
so it's difficult I mean I looked at one
early vertical video and this one I got
concerned with someone was narrating on
Facebook live and was literally saying
we ought to go out and kill some cops
because they just killed this man and he
was unarmed something to that effect so
he was really trying to incite now I
will tell you there were some at the
protest scene to talk to a couple of
command staff it was there and it was
during that time that some say that's
what you said and that's how it happened
I'm leaving this so that was very
encouraging I am told I had not had a
conversation with the family but I know
that a command officer had did have a
conversation explaining to the family
member of the family what had transpired
and the family of course was saddened by
the shooting but certainly respected the
fact that one someone told them what
happened and they they
part of the inciting clearly and then
you have folks who have said before
mayhem come from outside the city
Detroit and people in CID sort of tired
you know police department for the
people who live and work here and they
respect the job that we're doing and
when we make a mistake they understand
one thing we own it
we're transparent about it and we do
what we need to do so that there's not a
reoccurrence anytime it also has to use
deadly force it's very serious we know
it and the officers know it I don't I
don't think so
I won't even buy that I really believe
that you know most Detroiters and
certainly if this department you know
did something wrong I think they have
enough trust in this chief this
executive team that we're gonna do a
thorough unbiased investigation we run a
risk and we put information out like
this early but you know it's it's I it's
it's the city we have to manage and so
we understand that putting out
information sooner than later
is proper you know if you think about
what happened in Chicago with the tragic
shooting of Jaquan McDonald it took a
year I mean how do you build trust and
the mayor supports this you know we we
have we're in constant communication he
understands and so he understands the
necessity to get this information out
and get it out timely my staff would
tell you if I could have gotten it out
an hour ago two hours ago even but I
wanted to make sure that what we put out
was something that your viewers your
listeners could grasp and not just rely
on me standing there talking but again
within an hour and investigation I
essentially said
what happened and the video shows that
yes we talk all the time so we we talk
we converse we bounce things off each
other
the mayor trusts me to make decisions
and if I make a bad decision it's my
decision but the mayor trusts the
decision-making we've been talking about
I've called the president of the Police
Commission within that first hour to
advise mr. Bale of the events he
appreciated it I said it's very early in
an investigation and just like when i
briefed the mayor this is what I know
now you know these things evolve and
things change and while you see the
video we may get additional information
in the next 24 hours videos not going to
change there may be some facts that we
yeah we're do it one more time and I'll
shut it down for me okay well let
remember there are three video clips and
and I will shut it down after that we
let them look at the video please just
so they can can you start it from the
beginning is everybody ready
I want to take at some point you see
what appears to be the officer kicking
something that was the suspects gun
that's when you saw the kicking motion
he was actually kicking the gun away
from the reach of mr. Littleton can you
turn the lights out I'll take a few more
questions this officer is a hero he is
what I describe as an American Hero
despite being fired upon and you saw it
with your own eyes he continued to
advance his didn't even have time to
take his weapon out he advanced he
wanted to secure by putting his own life
in jeopardy he was trying to secure the
suspect and minimize the threat just
said - not even a few minutes ago
that the rumor that was circulating on
social media platform I don't know which
one that was erroneous
we don't know where folks are getting
that information yes I want to be
honored we don't know that we know that
where the shooting took place it was a
large-scale block party we do know that
there was a local gang involved we know
based on our intelligence that both mr.
Littleton and Sylvester had ties to a
local street gang but we were there
today to make an arrest of a person who
had an outstanding active felony warrant
for drugs and again he never resisted he
was taken into custody without incident
so I don't have that information a team
yes he does have a criminal history he
was on active probation if my memory
serves me I know yeah active probation
it was unarmed robbery and a weapons
charge and I think he was set to go off
probation in the year 2021 2020 well as
I said you know certainly police in the
day as a challenge I'm proud of the men
and women who go out each and every day
you know we certainly have been managing
protests now since late May and it were
at different times throughout the
protest the officers took a barrage of
insults at objects thrown they were
attacked and so really just the
professional decorum and again it's it's
been a tough time but I think what's so
different here in city Detroit our
police officers and I know that by and
large the short community supports this
department they support us I know I've
had numerous conversations with
community members all of the time not
just from Detroit but in the metro area
I know deputy chief Todd Medicine spends
a substantial amount of time in the
community we talked about our local
activists who have supported us I met
with a group of activists two days ago
to talk about issues that we could work
on together it was not a hostile meeting
it was a very productive meeting in fact
the fact that we have a drifting
community here that has supported us
and so this is called relationship
building we don't start building
relationships when something goes wrong
this is part of the fabric of the
Detroit Police Department critically
critically important they didn't know
anything about well I meet backup when
mr. Luton was approaching the officers
got information apparently he was
walking in the opposite direction
he observed that his friend or associate
was being detained and arrested that is
when he turns around and walks in the
direction of the officers he didn't try
to flee he walked in the direction of
the officer so he was clearly so
comments were made he was angry as I
indicated in my initial briefing about
his friend being arrested and without
hesitation he removed a handgun from his
left pants pocket
well we're releasing it now this is the
video release and I want to just truly
advise you that we're very early in its
investigation and so so I just ask that
you be somewhat patient and we'll get
you whatever you need this is about
transparency and this is how we conduct
our business each and every time there
were eight last count there were eight
arrested early on when the violence
started and again I want to stress you
use the word engage the violent core of
the protesters
present engaged the officers there being
to hurl projectiles I indicated brick
and one instance a cooler rocks I was
told bottles so there was engagement on
the part of the core group that were
angry and agitated you know I talked to
the commander who was on saying he made
the right decision it was a very active
violent situation he was met with
tremendous resistance and in my judgment
based on what I know about the
investigation
he did the right thing normally when we
talk about deployment of gas it's
usually when a group is stable and they
might be hurling but this got violent
very quickly the way it was described to
me and we had to make a decision he's a
commander and I support his decision
unless some other facts bear out but
clearly they were under attack in fact
that commander sustained an injury while
out trying to talk with the group he was
trying to reassure them because at some
point some of the other erroneous
information was being put out was that I
was being untruthful
and that this gentleman did not possess
a firearm it's a minor injury at least
we explained to me but I haven't gotten
the follow-up yet well you know it's
hard to make an assessment I mean I
don't want to this wasn't good we would
have hoped and again this is why this
knee-jerk reaction snapped reaction to
not knowing facts
is a problem and then when the people
that are projecting putting out
erroneous information is only from one
cause in one cause always to incite
others I mean I don't know of any other
reason I'll take one more question I
don't want to go into if there's a
penalty that I can just tell you what
other reason why a person would put out
information that doesn't support what
really happened in fact we know that
there was no one there they had the
information that I had I was very close
to the investigation
you know commander Decker who oversees
the homicide and certainly director
Gravlin who oversees professional
standards these are folks I rely on
getting accurate and timely information
and so why would someone take or
speculate as I say it when I first
started it's always tragic anytime the
police officer has to use deadly force
and again this hero despite being fired
upon responded still because he I can't
get into what was going through his head
but he clearly wanted to stop the
suspect even while putting himself in
direct calm that was clear in the video
so with that I thank you all for coming
out I have no idea I didn't even know
D'Amico was present but will as we go
through we'll take you okay thank you
for coming out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you